but I'm also joined I'm glad to say all
right Leon Panetta the former director
of the CIA and former Defense secretary
in America Mr Bernard thank you very
much indeed for joining me again on the
show we appreciate it
um we've talked before about Ukraine I
saw the president zielinski was a Davos
giving a he was talking to the people at
Davos saying this this has to end but
how do you see this ending
well I think it's very important uh at a
critical point in this war and it is a
critical point uh because uh it appears
to be a stalemate right now on the
ground uh in many ways I'm concerned
that it may favor uh the Russians uh and
the aggressor uh it'll allow them to dig
in to reinforce and to prepare for an
offensive so I think it's very important
now for the Allies to provide uh the
weapons that are essential to the
ukrainians uh heavy tanks missiles air
defense all of that ought to be provided
now uh in a
in an effort to try to give them the
ability to get the edge on an offensive
against the Russians this cannot be
allowed just simply to drag on uh that's
not going to that's not going to help
either party very frankly uh in terms of
trying to achieve uh some kind of ending
to this war
Britain is sending 12 tanks we know
others will be doing the same I mean
it's a very fine line isn't there
between supporting Ukraine in this
manner and actively engaging in this war
is it a line that the Russians May
deliberately blur are they trying to
indicate now that they may widen the war
if the West continues to support Ukraine
in a more direct manner
you know for for a year uh Russia has
threatened all kinds of consequences uh
that's the way they behave that's the
way Putin behaves uh and frankly we've
gone ahead regardless of those threats
and provided the weapons and provided
the support that is essential to the
ukrainians and I think we have to
continue to do that look the fundamental
issue is that we are fighting by by
supporting Ukraine and the ukrainians
who are fighting this War uh it's one of
the most important Wars of the 21st
century because in many ways the outcome
of this war will tell us a great deal
about what ultimately happens to
democracies in the 21st century so we
have a lot writing on making sure that
Ukraine is successful in this war there
was a hideous attack a few days ago in
the knee Pro on a residential block
gruesome videos I want to play a little
bit of one just to indicate the horror
of what is actually happening on the
ground there
is
I mean this is in the middle of a
sovereign Democratic country's City
and over 40 people were killed in an
attack on a residential building
I mean Mr Panetta when you see something
like that what are we seeing here are
these just war crimes
I think what we're seeing is uh the
Russians very clearly indicating that
they're not winning this war
and as a result they're going after
innocent men women and children uh and
conducting these kinds of horrific
attacks against uh innocent individuals
for me it's a reflection that Russia is
not winning but losing this War uh and I
think as a result of that the Allies
really need air defense systems we need
longer range missiles in order to make
sure that Russia uh their will to
continue to fight is broken Russia is
trying to hope that somehow the will of
the West may break
we have to basically provide the support
system to the ukrainians to break the
will of the Russians yeah I completely
agree there are two more things in order
to just to get your perspective on uh
one is Prince Harry the Duke of Sussex
has run into trouble diplomatically now
in this country from his base in America
with this book is written in which he
talked about killing 25 Taliban in
Afghanistan and he described you know
what people have accused him of being of
dehumanizing Enemy by describing them as
chess pieces not human beings to be
removed from a board and it's part of a
reaction predictable reaction from the
Taliban uh exploiting what he said but
it also is now uh inspired a reaction
from Iran who executed a British Iranian
on uh trump top suggestions he was a spy
and have issued a statement off the back
of what Harry said in Return for the
criticism about the execution to say the
the British regime his royal family
member seized the killing of 25 innocent
people as removal of chess pieces and
has no regrets over the issue and those
who turn a blind eye to this war crime
are in no position to preach others on
human rights what's your view about that
was Harry very misguided to put into a
book sold as many as it has done an
exact number of Taliban he killed and to
describe them as chess pieces
well appears based on based on my
experience uh uh both uh in the military
and as a secretary of defense
I have to tell you that the strongest
Warriors I knew in battle
were those who focused on the mission
uh and not uh how many uh individuals on
the other side that they killed they
focused on whether or not the mission
was accomplished and I think uh Prince
Harry would have done better to focus on
the missions that he was involved with
rather than counting the number of debt
so I I think in this situation
obviously Iran is is not a country uh
with a strong human rights record so
whatever they say I think uh we're not
to really pay a lot of attention to but
I do think that he could have handled
this better as a soldier would it be
sensible or be it he's already said this
but would it be sensible for future
editions of the book because they're
reprinting as we speak and given the
volume that it's selling would it be
sensible for him to maybe issue a
statement to calm things down to express
some regret over putting a number to his
his Taliban kill tally and to call them
chess pieces and to actually remove that
part from the book
yeah you know I
I think that
when you you start to detail how many
have been killed then in some ways that
becomes the issue and what I'm offended
by frankly is the Distortion of focusing
on numbers of killed rather than the
mission that he was involved with which
I think was a was a strong Mission an
important mission to go after the
Taliban and those who were involved in
the attack on 9 11. this was a this was
an important Mission and that's what
ought to be focused on so if in some way
he could kind of
rewrite this or or include the missions
that he was involved in without
referring to the number of people that
were killed I think that would frankly
represent a fairer description of what
he was involved with in his service I I
look he he I'm sure he performed well
I'm sure he did his service to his
country uh and I think that's important
but I think saying uh the number of
people that were killed frankly detracts
both from the mission and from the
service that he provided yeah I agree
and finally uh big story has been
brewing in America in the last few days
about President Biden and classified
documents that being found at his home
obviously we had this with President
Trump an ongoing investigation into that
you were obviously uh worked under the
Obama by Administration what is your
view of this I mean is there any
qualitative difference between the two
presidents here and how they've
mishandled classified documents and what
should happen to uh President Biden
well there is a concern here when you're
dealing with classified documents the
reality is that these documents require
that they be handled carefully that they
may be logged in and that they be secure
and for whatever reason that did not
happen it didn't happen with President
Trump uh in a very Reckless way frankly
in terms of the numbers of the documents
that are involved here uh and to the
same extent uh you know President Biden
made a mistake here and there was a
mistake either on his part or on the
status part for not being able to secure
those documents so I think the
appointment of a special console in both
cases is appropriate we need to find out
what happened we need to make sure that
it never happens again uh and so it is
it does detract from uh frankly uh you
know President Biden's effort to try to
say that what president Trump did was
wrong uh the fact is what he did is not
correct either so both are going to have
to face the consequences for the way
they mishandled classified documents
it's always great to have you on the
program because you always answer
questions honestly and directly and I
really appreciate it it's a rarity in
public life these days so please come
back again soon I appreciate it
thank you pierce good to talk to you all
the best